un ciel gris typique du sud-ouest de
l'angleterre
greta tanberg fait ses derniers pas sur
la terre ferme
ça va être une sacrée aventure dit la
jeune suédoise de 16 ans avant
d'embrasser ses proches et de partir
pour quinze jours de traversée ça fera
un an mardi qu'elle a commencé sa
scolarité fort climat tête la grève de
l'école pour le climat qui a influencé
des millions de jeunes
elle avait choisi le train en janvier
pour se rendre au sommet de davos
pas question de prendre l'avion pour
aller à la conférence de l'onu sur le
climat à new york le 23 septembre
la famille royale de monaco lui a donc
offert d'embarquer sur ce voilier
carboneutre ou presque
il ya des panneaux solaires et des
turbines explique le capitaine
cela suffit à alimenter les instruments
de bord
seul un peu de gaz servira à réchauffer
la nourriture déshydratée et comme l'a
constaté la jeune activiste en faisant
un essai hier le confort du voilier est
minimale quatre petits lits et un saut
en guise de toilettes pendant plus de
5500 km
pour plus de cohérence avec le discours
de l'écologiste bmw le commanditaire
habituel du voilier a accepté de retirer
son logo quant aux sceptiques les
climato sceptiques et les greta
sceptique je vais juste les ignorer ce
qui m'importe c'est que les dirigeants
réagissent avec forte
une fois de l'autre côté de l'atlantique
greta tonnes berg en profitera pour
venir au canada quelque part avant les
élections d'octobre ici mathieu prost
radio canada montréal